et on va continuer bien sûr à parler de
l'Ukraine selon le Haut Commissariat au
réfugié quelques 8 millions d'ukrainien
enfuient leur pays depuis un an depuis
le début de l'invasion russe quelques
cent mille ont trouvé refuge en France
nous sommes avec Maria comkovic réfugiés
ukrainienne à Paris bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être sur ce plateau ce soir
vous avez 28 ans vous travaillez dans le
cinéma vous étiez à Kiev le 24 février
dernier comment avez-vous vécu cette
terrible journée en fait cette journée
elle n'est pas c'était un choc mais il y
avait déjà un tout en moi de d'attente
de d'attention très forte et comme je
travaillais avec des Français sur les
films français qui étaient tournés en
Ukraine déjà il y avait beaucoup de
problèmes avec les assurances donc
personne ne pouvait assurer la bon fin
de films et on a perdu on avait plus de
projets on avait plus on a rendu nos
bureaux et du coup je je me suis
retrouvée dans une sorte de de
vide où j'avais plus de travail que
j'adorais et pour
pour ne pas rester désœuvré à manquer
tout le temps j'ai commencé à travailler
avec des journalistes notamment français
qui venait en Ukraine en attendant
quelque chose
dont personne n'était à 100% sûr et donc
j'essayais de trouver des des héros des
des
réservistes pour eux pour qu'il en parle
il leur seule question c'était est-ce
que la guerre va avoir lieu mais en fait
on sait pas et du coup le 23 non le 22
janvier j'avais j'ai organisé le voyage
asapoli j'ai hâte en groupe de
journalistes français aussi moi j'avais
je leur ai dit sincèrement que moi j'ai
peur d'y aller et que je pourrais pas
mais j'ai plus rien les billets d'avion
pour eux pardon de train et donc ils
sont partis et le rang 4 quand je me
réveille c'était une des premières
pensées enfin parce que c'est déjà c'est
toujours très paradoxal tu tu dis oh non
mais pourquoi je les ai envoyés enfin
comme si c'était de ma faute mais
finalement bon toutes c'est bien passé
avec eux mais moi je me suis réveillé
chez moi c'est ma copine qui m'a appelé
moi j'ai pas entendu les premières les
premières explosions
et
après on était tous pareils on a
commencé à c'était très
organiséationnel parce que on devait
juste comprendre comment et quel pas
faire juste pour traverser cette journée
et du coup on a commencé à on avait déjà
nos petits sacs de d'urgence déjà prêt
parce que ne les autorités ukrainiennes
et prévenaient quand même les gens de
d'être prêt à toutes sortes de
situations et du coup on a pris ses sacs
on a on est descendu dans le métro avec
les premières sirènes qu'on a entendu
pour
voir enfin pour rester ensemble aussi
parce que comme ça on avait au moins
l'impression qu'on était avec les autres
avec et donc on faisait même des petits
voyages sur les différentes stations de
métro pour voir nos amis et tout et
après
c'était
quelque chose de
même enfin à tout le monde et descendu
avec les animaux et tout il y avait pas
de bruit enfin il y avait pas de ça
ressemblait pas à l'enfer ça ressemblait
à quelque chose qui nous a tous réunis
tout le monde restait calme juste parce
que après
le pire c'est pas dans le métro qui va
vous arriver donc et quand avez-vous
finalement décidé de quitter l'Ukraine
et de rejoindre mon sens ça c'était
trois semaines après
d'abord je me suis rendu avec les amis à
moi à l'ouest de l'Ukraine ou vivait mes
parents et on est tous allés chez eux on
s'est tous installé chez eux on a
commencé à préparer la brillantibonde
parce que
on imaginait que la même chose allait
arriver aussi à l'ouest du l'Ukraine
parce que pourquoi essayer d'envoient
les missiles sur cueillir pourquoi pas
cher ici
et on a commencé à tout préparer et
pendant une semaine où on était très
occupés à organiser cette sorte de
nouvelle vie ça allait plus ou moins et
on était tout le temps accroché à nos
téléphones on les aide toutes les
actualités possibles en possibles au
mois de moitié c'était faux la moitié
c'était vrai mais des cris d'une manière
très étrange donc on était toujours on
était bourré d'informations très
oui très étrange et après quand on s'est
calmé juste parce que il y avait pas de
bombe à l'ouest de l'Ukraine on a arrivé
on est arrivé à plus ou moins organiser
la vie et j'ai compris que je sais pas
quoi faire et c'était une sorte de
dépression c'est parce que je
culpabilise parce qu'en fait c'est parce
qu'il est calme que je peux me permettre
d'être triste où c'est c'est quoi mon
problème et puis c'est des gens avec qui
je travaillais qui m'ont dit qui m'ont
proposé de venir en France aujourd'hui
vous êtes en France depuis
[Musique]